community brighton 8 news now is
sponsored by our community pride
partners finley automotive group
southwest medical part of optum care and
silver state schools credit union
annual enrollment period is coming to a
close soon rocky spoke with optim care
network's chief medicare director to
learn more
it is that time of the year of course we
always have you on talking about
medicare so let's just educate our
viewers really quick if someone doesn't
know you know what annual enrollment
period means what does that mean well
very good this is the time to choose a
medicare advantage plan that gives you
access to the care you need the medicare
annual enrollment period is now all the
way to december 7th
we want to make sure that the
information you need is out there for
these people to get the right choice
done
and the right choice is because there's
so many options what's that difference
between
medicare advantage over original
medicare that's a great question
traditional medicare has been around for
a long time and so is medicare advantage
the difference the key difference that
really grabs people initially is you
could save up to 40 percent of your
health care dollars personally by
picking a medicare advantage program
over traditional medicare
okay and then what steps should they
take during this annual enrollment
period where do they start
very good
first thing patients need to know is
know your needs right you want to be
sure that your primary care doctors
specialist and other providers are
covered by your insurance company the
optim care network offers a wide range
of primary and specialty care providers
across the whole valley when you need it
and this includes also
southwest medical which is you see it
all over the valley
uh there's actually and i'm gonna i'm
gonna go and talk about it right now we
have a very large nearly 3 000
in the whole state of providers
available through this program and i'd
like to just talk about four new ones we
just brought on dr mark ferdowsian
sunset clinics all over the valley dr
benito calderon from calderon medical
group we brought on dr leo capobianco
doctor center of red rock and dr william
jacks at premium family care those were
just two add-ons we just did constantly
growing the program uh many people take
more than three medications a month and
they need to make sure that their
medicare advantage plan pays for those
medications medicare advantage plan also
does other things that other traditional
medicare doesn't do
dental vision programs like that that
keep you healthy that aren't covered in
traditional medicare
good to know and i know you guys have
you know senior focused initiatives and
programs with southwest medical and
optum care so let's talk about that what
do you guys provide yeah no it's unique
uh we got a ro a wide range again like
i've spoken primary specialty all over
the valley but some of the key things we
offer that other people don't 24 7
telephone advice nurse you can speak to
a registered nurse any time to ask any
questions you may have about your health
that's amazing but it's just even better
24 7 virtual visits where you can
actually see a doctor for non-urgent
non-emergency health concerns you'll see
them on video in the comfort of your
home the final piece is we have a
program called at home visits with
dispatch health where a clinician will
come right to your home if it's kind of
a non-urgent non-emergency common
illness they can come right to your
house and see you face to face
thank you again to southwest medical
associates for being one of our
community pride partners las vegas